guys we have an update coming from ryan
reynolds himself on deadpool but first
do me a favor please subscribe turn on
notifications i am doing this every day
back in august of 2021 we had kevin
feige speaking with comicbook.com where
he said that the script is in the works
and that ryan reynolds is working very
hard on it with our writers as we speak
that was the last update that we got
officially from marvel studios and let
me tell you it is a long time coming
because ryan reynolds finally came out
and said let me quote we pretty much
talk about everything but i'll say this
about that particular subject is i'll
have a bunch of updates on that sooner
rather than later i hope
so i'll be able to get into stuff about
deadpool a little bit more clearly and
definitively down the road
i definitely believe that deadpool will
be jumping into the mcu within the next
two to three years if not sooner
see there is rumor going around that he
will somehow be popping up in the
post-credits scene of doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness uh there's
been the supposed leak and i say suppose
it because uh there's a lot of
controversy or at least um people
agreeing and disagreeing on whether or
not it's actually real understandably so
when it comes to these leaks you gotta
understand that there's a definite cause
for concern on whether it's legitimate
or not and that's personally what i deal
with on a daily basis trying to give you
guys these rumors and leaks here on the
hero daily which is fun for me i i enjoy
it very much but
as the casual sort of marvel fan you
definitely have to you have to take
every rumor and leak with just a little
bit of
um hesitation because there's a lot of
people out there that do it for the sole
reason of seeking fame and clout and
that's understandable i mean a lot of
people pay their bills with their social
media and whatnot but um it's definitely
harmful to
the
larger community of fans for the mcu
so let me know down below do you guys
see deadpool coming into the mcu within
the next two years or maybe three to
four years
um like i said i predict two to three
possibly around there let me know down
below what you guys think
again please hit subscribe
turn on notifications i am doing this
every day
and i'll see you guys tomorrow